hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 45 hört zu und spricht nach
matthias rutscht auf dem schnee aus
martin
ist auf dem schnee ausgerutscht
matthias ist auf dem schnee ausgerutscht
er hat sich sein
gebrochen
er hat sich seinen bei
thomas
fällt hin thomas
fällt hin
thomas ist hingefallen
er hat sich seinen knöchel verstaucht
er hat sich seinen
viel verstaucht
ich bin müde weil ich gestern spät ins
bett gegangen bin
ich bin
weil ich gestern spät ins bett gegangen
bin
ich bin nie
weil ich viel gearbeitet habe
ich bin müde weil ich viel gearbeitet
habe
ich bin glücklich weil ich die prüfung
bestanden habe ich bin glücklich weil
ich die prüfung bestanden habe ich bin
traurig weil ich mit meiner freundin
gestritten habe
ich bin traurig
ich weil ich mit meiner freundin
gestritten habe
der arzt hat gesagt dass du das
medikament nehmen sonst
medikament nehmen sollst
der arzt hat gesagt dass du nicht
rauchen sollst
ich bin krank ich bin krank mein sohn
ist krank
mein sohn ist krank
ich habe fieber
ich habe starken husten
ich habe eine allergie gegen
meeresfrüchte
ich habe eine allergie gegen katzen
ich habe
gegen katzen
katzen allergie ich habe eine
katzenallergie ich habe einen ausschlag
bekommen
ich habe einen ausschlag bekommen meine
blutgruppe ist positiv meine blutgruppe
ist positiv
mein hals tut weh mein
ich habe halsschmerzen
ich habe halt
merzen main
auch tut wie ein
auch tut wie ich habe bauchschmerzen
ich habe bauchschmerzen
mein kopf tut weh mein kopf tut weh
ich habe kopf
merzen ich habe
schmerzen ich brauche einen termin
ich brauche
min
cham
termin vereinbaren
kann ich einen termin vereinbaren
geht es nicht
ja
gibt es nicht früher
der termin ist zu spät
der termin
es ist zu spät der gips der gips der
verband die verbände der verband
die verbände
die pflegerin gleich die
krankenschwester
die krücke
die krücken
die operation
[Musik]
die operationen
die tablette die tabletten
das spital
die spitäler
die spritze
die spritzen
der unfall
die unfälle
die beerdigung die beerdigungen
die
die epidemien
die epidemie wie epidemien